hello you welcome to silver it's and
welcome back to planet soo now today is
all about the Indian elephants and I'll
be building a separate habitat for them
again
perhaps this will be my last separate
habitat build we'll see if I feel ready
to take over for Zoo after this but many
comments have been asking me recently if
I'm ever gonna actually start a zoo and
I have to say yes eventually I would
like to do this but for now this is a
very different new experience for me
this is a very new game and I want to
really experiment as much as I can
before I move into a for zoo so I hope
you understand that but yeah back to the
topic at hand I was inspired to start a
Thai build not just because I'm
interested in the architecture and the
whole theme of it but also just because
these strange events that have been
happening over the last few weeks
basically my audience on this platform
has completely shifted some of the
biggest countries for me in terms of
audience always used to be the United
States Germany and the United Kingdom
with the Netherlands sometimes on a
fourth or third position but recently
the suddenly Thailand is skyrocketed and
became the second biggest group in my
demographic at least according to view
counts it's no idea that in subscribers
because it's really just due to recent
attention but basically what happened is
there's a Thai youtuber which started
making videos on planet coaster and
planet soo called Hart rocker and who
has created a lot of buzz for these
games in Thailand and this difference is
really substantial I've heard from some
inside sources that apparently the sales
figures for planet coaster have
increased by 50 percent over the the
last few weeks which is absolutely
insane and this happened even before
planets who came out and the same kind
of goes for planets zoo I suppose
because heart workers also been making a
lot of videos on this but for me
personally there's another reason which
is a much bigger reason for my toy
orience
but I think this is probably related to
the skyrocketing popularity of these
games in Thailand and that is that at
Wii
went viral about my Volvo a build in
planet coaster and got like sixty
thousand retweets on Twitter and just
sort of became this viral tight wheat
that also drew a lot of attention to the
games and to my channel in particular so
yeah there's been a really cool
happening and it's been really
interesting to see so much attention to
these games also coming from a country
and a region in the world that otherwise
I don't see reflected in the community
as much over all these kinds of games
have always seemed very sort of North
Western Europe and us centric especially
the Netherlands for some reason I'm not
sure but there are just such huge parts
of the community of these creative
simulation games that are always Dutch
and I really don't know why because
there are only about 17 million Dutch
people in this world which is quite a
few but it's way fewer than the UK and
US and despite this they often have
almost just as large audiences in these
kinds of games but yeah that's way off
topic I just found it really interesting
that there's sort of this large new
audience from a different part of the
world coming to this and I guess I am
just trying to play to my audience with
this in a sense and try and tackle a
Thai theme as well which is either a
great idea or a terrible idea given that
people are probably gonna be able to
bust my nuts about this given that I'm
not gonna be building anywhere near as
properly Thai themed as people from this
part of the world I could probably do I
might be inviting some heavy critics
here but I loved high architecture just
all the different styles of Asian
architecture in general and a long time
ago in planet coaster me and Rudy Ren
Kemal made Garuda which was a Thai
themed RMC roller coaster and after that
I always just thought it was one of my
favourite themes that I've ever done
especially with the focus on these
pointed roofs and all of the detailing
around it so I always wanted to do it
and right about now seems like a good
time to try it also given the fact that
I'm still doing you know standalone
habitats and I can just mess about with
the game and experiment now let me
finally talk about what I'm actually
doing here so right now I'm working on a
building which is heavily inspired by
Buddhist temples in Thailand which is a
theme that I'm gonna be following for
much of the rest of this habitat as well
and the idea for this building was to
make it the main viewing shelter I was
inspired by these pavilions that you
often find in temple complexes called
the Sala I don't know exactly how to
pronounce Thai words so I'm probably
gonna be putting emphasis as wrong and
things like these on words but yeah it's
this this kind of open pavilion style
building which you often find in temple
complexes in Thailand which
traditionally supposedly were used to
land Travelers Rest and things like this
and which I think provide a really cool
structure to create a guest viewing
platform out of four habitats because
very often and you habitat especially
for the sort of charismatic megafauna
you'll have some kind of shelters for
guests to view the animals from and I
figured if I'm gonna try and go with a
very heavily themed habitats I want to
as always keep the theming and the
architecture really restricted to the
guests side of things and basically
making a sort of open temple viewing
shelter structure seems like a good idea
in that sense now I have to say I was
struggling a lot with making this
because I was mostly basing this on a
pavilion in the or bridge botanical
gardens in medicine although with
different colors and details based on
what's available in the game but it
turned out to be really quite a struggle
because for one I need to make all of
the roof pieces completely custom
because the game doesn't have these
pointy curved roof pieces that I'm the
for this team you know even though there
is an a there's an East Asian theme this
is really typically Japanese and Chinese
elements and very few of that set I
think could be used to build Southeast
Asian theme specifically Thai
architecture so I have to make a lot
myself here and this is not necessarily
an issue I think there are a fair amount
of pieces that you can use to make
custom roofs out of in this case I ended
up using the wooden beams the small
one-meter versions from the East Asian
Pack to make custom roof shingles and
sort of curved these upwards to make
these typical Thai curved pointed roofs
which worked alright but it didn't mean
that this building contains thousands of
pieces it's somewhere between 7,000 and
8,000 pieces by the time that I'm done
and I wasn't really expecting this to be
that much of an issue I've done this
sort of thing many times in planet
coaster and gotten away with it but for
some reason planets who started really
struggling with this and before I
complain too much about this I have to
admit this is not the kind of thing that
developers want you to do I'm sure that
if anybody who worked on the programming
of this game is seeing me do this
they're cringing really hard because
it's just way too taxing on the game
itself but yeah I want to have my type
roofs and I'm gonna get them one way or
another but yeah this this game just
started struggling with this alone and
the game started freezing many times
especially whenever I was building
around the roof I would get these twenty
to thirty second freezes when I was
placing or removing something and this
made it a really time-consuming sort of
effort to build this building and you
can see some of these freezes happening
on the time-lapse every now and then I
suppose this is sped up about twelve
times so hopefully there won't be much
more than just a sort of infrequent
jitter or framerate but yeah just so you
know that is the reason why every now
and then the time-lapse despite being of
time-lapse might not be that smooth in
terms of frame rate and also why I just
took so
to build this building and some of the
other stuff around this habitat as well
because it's just really difficult to
work with this and I don't want to
attack the game for this because it's
really not what you're supposed to do or
at least I cannot demand from the
developers that they can make that they
can make the game support this kind of
ridiculous building behavior but it was
kind of a bummer
and it made building this this whole
structure a little bit annoying I also
have to say there were a bunch of other
grievances then I've since been patched
out so for example the X button kept
crashing on me and I would have to move
stuff with the with with a mouse
basically and using the 3d gizmo like
that which is a little bit annoying that
that that bug has been patched out since
in the last update it's just that this
footage is already kind of old so it's
still made with the first version of the
game or the second update which still
had about a bunch of bugs in it and then
also the recoloring options in the game
we're still problematic because you
couldn't recolor multiple objects at the
same time I did find a workaround for
this I would typically just take a bunch
of objects that I wanted to recover out
of a building make them a separate
scenery group and then just recolor that
scenery group and then afterwards
reintegrate them into the building so
there were some workarounds for some of
this but I was kind of struggling with
these kinds of things and because of
that I think I wasn't building as
efficiently as I could have otherwise
done that's why this is also a 30 minute
video so I hope you guys are sitting
comfortably and got something to eat got
something to snack maybe maybe you're
doing something else
and you're just checking making
time-lapse every now and then just
listening to me talk on and on about
Thai roof structures that's also fine
but yeah just this is kind of my
explanation for this is a very why this
is a very long-winded video now I'll
come back to the viewing shelter later
it's actually a little bit unfinished as
of now I still want to add some
detailing to it later and I want to add
a spa
on top of it so it's not exactly what I
was looking for but at this point I felt
like I was done working on this thing
because it's been about two hours of
just working on that roof so I just
wanted to move on to some other things
and actually give this building a
context finish some of the surrounding
area as well so here's the connection to
the path it is actually going to be
functional so people are going to be
able to walk up the stairs and go into
the building I did work out a different
sort of path grid system within the
building so that people wouldn't look in
wouldn't walk into the pillars because
if the whole building were just one big
plaza and I put the pillars in the
middle of it you know you would
sometimes catch some people you know
walking through the pillars which is
something that I didn't want to have so
what I ended up doing is just building
every path on a four grid on a four
meter grid and having these little paths
going between the pillars and then
covering all of that up later with
regular flat roof pieces so that the
texture that you see is actually a roof
piece and underneath that will be these
different paths work paths then people
can walk through so that they take some
pretty sort of predetermined paths
through the building that don't cross
through the pillars which sometimes is a
neat workaround if you're trying to make
you know a very wide area seem like it's
one part or one plaza but you don't want
people to walk through everything like
people will in this game if you just put
scenery on the path then doing something
like that and covering the paths up I
think he can work now speaking of the
path system I was kind of struggling
here to make this next structure that I
wanted to build my idea for this was I
wanted to build a small viewing platform
that would be raised and almost in the
middle of the habitat if you will so
that you could take a bridge to it and
once you're in this viewing platform you
have almost a 360-degree view of the
elephant's exhibits because that would
be right underneath the path here so
it's a little bit more immersive than
just stand
and a distance and looking at the
elephants the far away in one direction
but you can actually have elephants in
different directions around this
platform which I thought would be a
slightly more interesting way to
interact with them and also a way to
give the guests different ways to view
the elephants from so I thought that
would be nice to add then over here on
this side with this retaining wall kind
of structure made out of the habitat
boundaries is is more of a sort of
standard viewing area for the habitat
just a path and a distance kind of
raised to present to prevent the
elephants from getting out of course but
yeah that's a much more simple way of
tackling the issue of how guests can
actually view the animals I suppose now
this structure was inspired by eight
different elements in Thai Taiwanese
type is a Taiwanese in Thai temples
which is well according according from
my research at least something called a
cootie which is a traditional living
space for monks on temple grounds or
near temple grounds which are often
small wooden buildings on stilts
nowadays apparently they are more often
just simple apartment building complexes
or things like this but referring to the
sort of traditional inspiration I found
that a lot of these temple complexes
have these small buildings on stilts and
I figured I can't really exactly copy
this style but something invoking this
same kind of typology could work out
very well for this raised viewing
shelter so that's what I decided to go
for now because this is a little bit
less of a fancy building I'm also going
with slightly different textures it's
made out of wood mostly instead of the
very fancy probably marble in real life
parts of the larger shelter and also the
overall colors are a bit more diminished
and dark and gritty so you can also tell
that from the wooden shingles that I'm
making here now what I also wanted to
experiment with a bit more and this is I
think you know besides the shape one of
the biggest advantages of making custom
roofs you can actually have some
variation in the texture so of course
you can make custom roofs if you want to
go for a certain shape like the pointed
roof which I'm doing here because
there's not one in game but you can also
click on different objects that you've
made the roof out of and give them
different colors or different positions
or shapes to slightly change the texture
because you really get this sort of
three-dimensional texture on this
because of course every single tile is
really a separate object which from a
game perspective is a terrible idea and
you should never do this because it's
just way too hard on the processing
power of your computer and it's just
gonna screw up a lot of players of the
game but since it's just me and I don't
have to answer for the performance of
the game I can make this roof out of
separate pieces and as you can see I'm
making the details or the the shingles
here gradually darker toward the top
just as a sort of weathering effect
which i think is one of these touches
that is is one of the reasons why you
would potentially want to make a roof
custom just to provide that little bit
of variation it's a really small thing
but I think it makes a huge difference
even if just because I wanted to build
this this building to seem a bit more
old and to seem a little bit more
dilapidated and it's slightly less of a
fancy structure than the main viewing
shelter hence I'm also completely
rebuilding this pointy roof because it
is slightly different than the other one
and I'm using different pieces for this
one these are I believe small blank
pieces which in hindsight I do think are
a little bit better because they're
flats instead of the very thick large
wooden beam pieces that I made the roof
of the main viewing shelter out of so
that works a bit better in this
situation but yeah aside from that it's
a very similar strategy just layering
these things in the shape of a pointed
roof until you pretty much have a roof
structure now as a tip for people who
want to make these kind of roofs
themselves
you've probably seen me just use an
in-game roof as a
and I would highly recommend just doing
that because it's a great guy to see how
large a full tile is because ideally you
would like to make these custom roofs
you know exactly fit on a full tile so
that you can repeat them and connect
them together and it also just helps to
keep them on a grid as well because if
you don't have at least one part of this
roof that also is restricted to the grid
in the game it's gonna be very difficult
to copy these roofs around and make them
seamlessly connect to each other since
if you don't have a great piece they
just kind of loosely float in the game
so I feel like these are some important
pointers to keep in mind when you're
building custom roofs but yeah that's it
for the roof structure of this building
it's much simpler than the other
building I built and to be honest after
that whole experience of trying to make
the mute the main viewing shelter I
really didn't want to bother too much
with this one and keep it all a bit more
simple now with that said and got we're
nearly twenty minutes into this video
and I've barely even water even worked
on the habitat itself so with that said
I'm actually starting to work on the
habitat here and my idea for this
originally was mostly inspired by the
elephant yard in Chinchin natty Zoo it's
not actually how you pronounce that city
maybe I messed it up maybe it maybe I
did either way it was inspired by that
which I found some interesting plans for
so this is mostly this sort of makeup of
the paths and the location of the
viewing shelters but then I used the
Chester Zoo Indian elephant exhibits on
zoo legs as a reference along the way
mostly because there's a lot of
information on zoo likes about this
exhibit and it was just something to
keep in the background when I was
working on this and to constantly refer
to as a reference for whatever I was
building to to make sure that I would
actually be a logical thing to do partly
because Chester Zoo is just really such
a well known and recognized - in
fun facts actually and I don't even know
where I learned this from but Chester
Zoo was apparently the main inspiration
for the developers of Planet Zoo as well
and the main zoo that they constantly
looked at when they were thinking about
adding something into the game and they
constantly looked for a source of
inspiration so I thought that was really
interesting but honestly quite
understandable because as far as I know
Chester Zoo is one of if not the best -
in Europe so definitely something to
keep in mind and there's a lot of
information about it on Zoo likes as
well and I've already advertised to
likes a bit before but it's just this
really good website with information and
pictures about the wide variety of zoo
habitats which is super useful and I
have to give a shout out to nutria here
on Twitter for sending me this link to
zoo likes a long time ago and I believe
he also tagged a bunch of other people
like geek ISM in this because it really
helps out a lot ever since he'll I
actually have to give him props also for
just giving me a lot of information on
Twitter in general and he works at a zoo
in Germany somewhere and he's just been
chatting to me a lot about you know
giving tips on the game and how to build
realistic habitats which I have to be
honest I'm a total noob so I need this
kind of thing because I might know a bit
or two about architecture and
landscaping but when it comes to animal
welfare that's my main weak points and
conversely the thing that you should
probably pay most attention to when
you're trying to make a Zoo so I'm
really glad that he's being so helpful
and again I guess like I always say if
there's anything that you think I did
wrong or that I could improve please let
me know it'd just be as harsh as you can
because that's the only way that I can
really improve my game now he did
mention a couple of things then I'm
gonna say right now are completely wrong
about this habitat that I built here
because I built this habitat before I
started chatting with him recently and
some notes that he gave me
are that elephants eat absolutely every
green thing they can find in their reach
and I ended up putting a lot of trees a
lot of very lively trees and bushes as
well in this habitat which realistically
probably doesn't make that much sense
because by the time the elephants are
done with it they should be dead but I
guess we'll just assume that this
habitat is brand new it's all still very
alive and it's all still very much like
the renders of architects intended
speaking of which I'm I'm not surprised
that's a lot of architecture firms work
on habitats in zoo as well and their zoo
habitat renders are just as fancy and
over-the-top as real building renders
this is really you know architectural
renders or always kind of like the
pictures in fast-food joints where you
see a beautiful hamburger on the screen
and then you get it and it's just a
piece of garbage that's that's basically
what a lot of architectural renders do
as well and I feel like for zoos they do
pretty much the same kind of thing and I
don't know I always thought that was
interesting obviously they want to sell
the thing that they've designed and
renders are always kind of a sort of
utopian vision of real life but it's
just this this kind of funny thing that
translate from that that translates
almost perfectly from the architectural
world into the the world of designing
zoos as well it seems but yeah what was
I even talking about before that I guess
my my sort of bridge here is that yeah
this habitat is brand-new and it still
kind of like it would be represented on
an architectural render with a lot of
greenery and foliage that realistically
is a little bit over the top not to
mention that the art the architecture
especially the main viewing shelter is a
little bit over the top as well even if
Sue's in real life do you commonly have
this kind of grandiose detailed
architecture as well
now nutria did give me the tip of
working on subtle ways to keep animals
in certain places not just within their
habitats but also to keep them away from
trees and things like this in their
habitats to use hot wires or untrue
versa ball rock elements on the ground
to stop them which is something that I'm
definitely gonna want to try in the
future but I have to say in this game I
don't think it's gonna make much of a
difference in real life you can put
small rocks and pebbles on the ground to
make certain barriers for animals that
they don't want to step on but in
planets who I think they are gonna walk
on pretty much anything solid so we'll
see something to experiment with in the
future
just to see how you can make more subtle
and invisible barriers and divisions of
habitats
speaking of which and this is something
which I can't believe I haven't said yet
but this isn't just one habitats in game
this whole area is actually made up of
two habitats and if you were a viewer
who pays attention you might have
noticed that I put a fence in the middle
of the water somewhere to the side of
those habitats and the idea behind this
was to basically just have one main area
where I would put the whole bunch of
elephants and then also a separate ball
yard if I ever needed to you know have
some elephant separates especially some
guys then I can dump them in there so
just realistically speaking being able
to keep animals in separate habitats and
having these kind of pool yards and
things are something that you
necessarily see in zoos so something
that I wanted to include here even if
it's just a bit basic because I don't
really have a backyard or backstage yard
away from guests where I could keep
elephants separate as well which
realistically I could have tried to
include as well but just in this case I
wanted to try and make this sort of
large area which seems like one habitat
and where guests can see all of the
elephants but where in reality I can
separate some of them and here I'm just
working on a waterfall
and I know how I've complained about
youtubers building waterfalls in every
exhibits before on social media if not
in my videos as well I can't really
remember when it comes to elephants I I
really wanted to have a waterfall
because these things are such a staple
of elephant habitats they're also really
important just because elephants really
need to be near water and they need to
have a large amount of water in their
exhibits in real zoos as well so it's
nice to have this water elements also
and I think it works quite well with the
main viewing temple building it's just
kind of this scene which I set up
obviously the waterfall is also partly
an elements of decoration for the guests
to look at even if elephants couldn't
care less
well how nice the rock work is or how
beautiful the foliage looks together
it's something then just for guest
reasons I'd want to keep in mind as well
and here I'm putting a bunch of dead
trees which in hindsight is a bit more
realistic than the actual alive trees
which I put in the rest of the habitats
because realistically this is what the
trees are gonna look like but no I just
figured that it would look good in this
area because I wanted to put something
there but I didn't want to obstruct the
rest of the view of the habitats so
that's why it works to have some dead
trees in a habitat as well but of course
realistically it also works out because
it's some form of scenery and some form
of nature but at the same time the
animals can't really destroy it much or
anything like that so I suppose this is
also why you'll find a lot of dead trees
in zoo exhibits as well so this is
almost the end of the time-lapse this is
one more thing that I needed to do
before this habitat was finished and
that is at the final spire on top of the
main viewing building now I actually
tried looking up with some of the names
of the different elements are of
traditional Thai temple architecture and
there are definitely some interesting
elements you've got Chava which are the
pointed ends of the roof
which are decorations that I'll add
off-camera at some point as well to
finish the main buildings and Lum young
which are apparently the name of the
decorative structures at the end of the
gables of the roof which are really cool
and really a sort of characteristic
elements of these Thai temples and I
really love decorated gables I'm also a
big fan of them in Swiss Chalet
architecture and things like this but I
couldn't really find the specific name
for the sort of rounded pointed spires
in the middle of temples so if anybody
knows of this please let me know because
it's been on my mind for a while and I
couldn't really find it but in any case
this structure on top of the building is
based on these rounded spires that you
often find on temples as well and with
that I would like to finish this episode
so thank you guys for watching and I'll
leave you with some cinematic views of
the elephants enjoying their new
habitats and for the record before I
forget to mention this as well I didn't
record any stats but as far as I've been
able to tell the stats on the elephants
are fine and they're all green and
they're somehow even happy with the
foliage which is mostly wrong not
entirely happy but decent enough I think
anyway bye guys
[Music]
[Music]